now you were not the guy they chose for
Breaking Bad originally right they
wanted to go with a big name they wanted
to go with like a Matthew Broderick I
heard and the other one was I heard John
Cusack
it's weird I can't imagine anybody else
doing it yeah
well I had the Good Fortune of working
for Vince Gilligan 10 years earlier on
an episode of X-Files I don't know that
the offer actually went out for Breaking
Bad I think you know because Vince
Gilligan was my Champion to get this
role he wanted you yeah he did because
we worked together he thought the
character that he wrote on that episode
of X-Files had a lot of the same
characteristics that that Walter White
needed in other words you played a guy
who is bad yeah but you understand that
he also has good quality exactly right
yeah because I I think your character is
a good guy in a way in a way yeah it's
it's very it's it's hard to figure out
that ambivalence uh throughout the whole
series are you able to memorize lines
rapidly I I can yeah I did I did a soap
wrapper here in New York for uh and you
can memorize that whole script
you can yeah you know what I mean
memorization is is really two things
it's it's repetitive
so any uh you know two-year-old knows
the the song of Happy Birthday to you
right and that's just because they've
heard it a few times now then you take
you take repetitiveness and connecting
it to an emotion and you tie in so I do
what's called margin work so I'll I'll
think of what the key word to Any Given
sentence is yeah I'll put it in my
margin then I can I can do a whole page
worth of of dialogue cover it up and
just read those keywords and then the
whole sentence starts coming to you how
long does that take I mean because it
seems to me some some of these uh
Breaking Bad episodes you're the whole
yeah so it's almost like a monologue
yeah and you've got to memorize a whole
you have to memorize it word for word in
other words it's Vince Gilligan say look
this is the way I wrote it I want it
done this way yes and if you change a a
word he'll say do it again there are a
lot of writers who want it verbatim that
sounds like homework this is not your
part
essentially not a drug guy and stuff
it's kind of weird to like try to play
that culture and every everything but
although yeah but he does yeah right
right yeah he's the guy who doesn't yeah
do you ever look into making meth I mean
not as a career but like can you imagine
would you like to actually know how to
make meth we we uh we're taught how to
make meth oh you work really DEA uh
chemists who were our Consultants on the
show did you actually cook meth we well
didn't cook it but we we were told
exactly the process at that high level
you're gonna try it one day I mean
seriously would you like to just cook a
little bit I mean if you've played it
for so long
yeah there are so many uh volatile
components to it that at any given time
you could literally blow up wow so uh
you had to be very careful and very
specific to follow this so there really
are in real life better meth Cooks than
others oh absolutely yeah and and most
of the cooks are also meth heads
themselves that's why they get
themselves in trouble and you see burn
marks on them like their hands are
missing you said uh Breaking Bad I bet
you're kind of happy in a way it's like
you did your run on that and then you'll
go do something else yeah it's good I
mean I I don't want it to end like uh
some some [ __ ] story where it's like
oh hey you know what we had we had the
wrong charts you're fine we can go on
for another yeah five years right no
it's but do you think you'll ever get
another role like that no no this is the
greatest role of my life I know that I
will never have another role as good as
as Walter White